my novel turtles all the way down was
published in october
of 2017 and after spending that month on
tour for the book
i came home to indianapolis and blazed a
trail
between my children's tree house and the
little room
where my wife and i often work a room
that depending on your world view
is either an office or a shed
this was not like a metaphorical trail
it was an actual trail in the woods
and to make it i cleared dozens of the
prolific and
invasive honeysuckle trees that choke
much of central indiana
and i dug up the english ivy that had
taken over
and then i covered the path in wood
chips and lined it with bricks
i worked on the path 10 or 12 hours a
day
five or six days a week for a month and
when i finally finished
i timed myself walking along the path
from our office to the tree house
58 seconds it took me a month
to build a 58 second walk in the woods
a week after finishing this path i was
searching through a drawer
for some chapstick when all at once and
without any warning
my balance failed the world began to
roll
and spin i was suddenly a very small
boat
in very high seas my eyes
shivered in their sockets and i began
vomiting
and was rushed to the hospital for weeks
afterwards
the world spun and spun
eventually i was diagnosed with
labyrinthitis
a disease of the inner ear with a
wonderfully
resonant name that is nonetheless an
unambiguously
one-star experience recovery from
labyrinthitis
meant weeks in bed unable to read or
watch tv
or play with my kids i had only my
thoughts at times
drifting through a drowsy sky at other
times
panicking me with their insistence and
omnipresence
during these long still days my mind
traveled all over
roaming through the past
the writer allegra goodman was once
asked whom would you like to write your
life story
and she answered i seem to be writing it
myself
but since i'm a novelist it's all in
code
and for me it had started to feel like
some people
thought they knew the code they would
assume i
shared the world view of a book's
protagonist or
they'd ask me questions as if i were the
protagonist
one famous interviewer asked me if i
also
like the narrator of turtles all the way
down experienced
panic attacks when kissing i had invited
such questions i suppose by having a
public life as a mentally ill person
but still talking so much about myself
in the context of fiction
became exhausting for me and a little
destabilizing
i told the interviewer that no i do not
have anxiety
around kissing but i do experience panic
attacks and they are intensely
frightening
and as i talked i felt distant from
myself
like myself wasn't really mine but
instead
something i was selling or at the very
least renting out
in exchange for good press as i
recovered from labyrinthitis
i realized i didn't want to write in
code anymore
in 2000 i worked for a few months as a
student chaplain
in a children's hospital i was enrolled
in divinity school at the time
and planning to become an episcopal
minister but
my time at the hospital disavowed me of
those plans
i couldn't handle the devastation i saw
there
i still can't handle it instead of going
to divinity school
i moved to chicago and found work as a
typist for temp agencies
before eventually landing a job doing
data entry for book list magazine
a bi-weekly book review journal a few
months later
i got my first chance to review a book
after an editor asked me if i liked
romance novels
i told her i loved them and she gave me
a novel set in 17th century london
over the next five years i reviewed
hundreds of books for book list
from picture books about the buddha to
poetry collections
and in the process i became fascinated
by the format of the review booklist
reviews were limited to 175 words
which meant every sentence had to work
multiple jobs
each review had to introduce a book
while also analyzing it
your compliments needed to live right
alongside your concerns
at book list reviews do not include
ratings on a 5 star scale
why would they in 175 words one can
communicate
far more to potential readers than any
single data point
ever could the five-star scale has only
been used in critical analysis for the
past few decades
while it was occasionally applied to
film criticism as early as the 1950s
the five-star scale wasn't used to rate
hotels until 1979
and it wasn't widely used to rate books
until amazon introduced user reviews
the five-star scale doesn't really exist
for humans
it exists for data aggregation systems
which is why it did not become standard
until the internet era
making conclusions about a book's
quality from a 175 word review
is hard work for artificial
intelligences whereas
star ratings are ideal for them
it's tempting to make labyrinthitis a
metaphor
my life lacked balance and so i was
devastated by
a balance disorder i spent a month
drawing
a straight line of a trail only to be
told that life is never
simple paths only dizzying labyrinths
that fold in on themselves
even now i find myself structuring this
introduction
like a maze coming back to places i
thought i'd left
but this symbolization of disease is
exactly what i tried to write
against in my novels turtles all the way
down and the fault in our stars
where i hope at least ocd and cancer
are portrayed not as battles to be won
or
symbolic manifestations of character
flaws or whatever
but as illnesses to be lived with as
well as one
can i did not get labyrinthitis because
the universe wanted to teach me a lesson
about balance so i tried to live with it
as well as i could within six weeks i
was mostly better
but i still experience bouts of vertigo
and they are terrifying i know now
with a viscerality i didn't before
that consciousness is temporary and
precarious
it's not a metaphor to say that human
life is a balancing act
as i got better i wondered what i would
do with the rest of my life
i went back to making a video every
tuesday and a weekly podcast with my
brother
but i wasn't writing that fall and early
winter was the longest i'd gone without
trying to write for an audience since i
was 14 years old
i suppose i missed writing but in the
way you miss someone
you used to love i left book list and
chicago
in 2005 because my wife sarah got into
graduate school in new york
when she finished her degree we moved to
indianapolis
where sarah worked for the indianapolis
museum of art
as a curator of contemporary art and we
have lived here ever since
i read so much at book list that i can't
remember
when i first came across the word
anthropocene
but it must have been around 2002
the anthropocene is a proposed term for
the current geologic
age in which humans have profoundly
reshaped the planet's biodiversity
and its geology nothing is more human
than
aggrandizing humans but we are a hugely
powerful force on earth in the 21st
century
my brother hank who started out his
professional life as a biochemist
once explained it to me like this as a
person
he told me your biggest problem is other
people
you are vulnerable to people and reliant
upon
them but imagine instead that you are a
21st century
river or desert or polar bear
your biggest problem is still humans
you are still vulnerable to them and
reliant upon them
hank had been with me on that book tour
in the fall of 2017
and to pass the time on long drives
between cities
we'd try to one-up each other with
absurd google user reviews for the
places we drove
past a user named lucas for example
gave badlands national park one star
not enough mountain he reported in the
years since i'd been a book reviewer
everyone had become a reviewer and
everything had become a subject for
reviews
the five-star scale was applied not just
to books and
films but to public restrooms and
wedding photographers
the medication i take to treat my
obsessive-compulsive disorder
has more than 100 ratings at drugs.com
with an average score of 3.8 a scene in
the movie adaptation
of my book the fault in our stars was
filmed on a bench in amsterdam
and that bench now has hundreds of
google reviews
my favorite three-star review reads in
its entirety
it is a bench as hank and i
marveled at the sudden every awareness
of reviewing on a five-star scale
i told him that years earlier i'd had an
idea to write a review of canada geese
hank said the anthropocene reviewed
i'd actually written a few of these
reviews back in 2014
the one about canada geese and also one
about diet dr pepper
in early 2018 i sent those reviews to
sarah
and asked for her thoughts when i
reviewed books
i was never in the review i imagined
myself as a disinterested observer
writing from outside my early reviews of
diet dr pepper and canada geese
were similarly written in the
non-fictional version
of third-person omniscient narration and
after
sarah read them she pointed out that in
the anthropocene
there are no disinterested observers
there are only participants she
explained that when people write reviews
they are really writing a kind of memoir
here's what
my experience was eating at this
restaurant or
getting my hair cut at this barber shop
i'd written 1500 words about diet dr
pepper
without once mentioning my abiding and
deeply personal love of diet dr pepper
around the same time as i began to
recover my sense of balance
i reread the work of my friend and
mentor amy kraus rosenthal
who died a few months earlier she had
once written
for anyone trying to discern what to do
with their life
pay attention to what you pay attention
to
that's pretty much all the info you need
my attention had become so fractured
and my world had become so loud that i
wasn't paying attention to what i was
paying attention to
but when i put myself into the reviews
as sarah suggested
i felt like for the first time in years
i was at least
trying to pay attention to what i pay
attention to
this book started out as a podcast where
i tried to chart some of the
contradictions of human life
as i experience it how we can be so
compassionate
and so cruel so persistent and so quick
to despair above all
i wanted to understand the contradiction
of human power
we are at once far too powerful
and not nearly powerful enough we are
powerful enough to
radically reshape earth's climate and
biodiversity
but not powerful enough to choose how we
reshape them
we are so powerful that we have escaped
our planet's atmosphere
but we are not powerful enough to save
those we love
from suffering i also wanted to write
about some of the places where my small
life
runs into the large forces of the
anthropocene
and then in early 2020 after two years
of writing the podcast
an exceptionally large force appeared in
the form of a novel coronavirus
i began then to write about the only
thing i could write about
amid the crisis and writing to you from
april
of 2021 i am very much still omitted
i find much to fear and lament
but i also see humans working together
to share
and distribute what we collectively
learn and i see people working
together to care for the sick and the
vulnerable
even separated we are bound up in each
other
as sarah told me there are no observers
only participants at the end of his life
the great picture book author and
illustrator maury sendak
said on the npr show fresh air i cry a
lot
because i miss people i cry a lot
because they die
and i can't stop them they leave me
and i love them more he said
i'm finding out as i'm aging that i'm in
love
with the world it has taken me
all my life up to now to fall in love
with the world
but i've started to feel it in the last
couple years
to fall in love with the world is not to
ignore or overlook
suffering both human and otherwise
for me anyway to fall in love with the
world is to look up at the night sky
and feel your mind swim before the
beauty and the distance
of the stars it is to hold your children
while they cry to watch as the sycamore
trees
leaf out in june when my breastbone
starts to hurt
and my throat tightens and tears well in
my eyes
i want to turn away from feeling i want
to deflect
with irony or anything else that will
keep me
from feeling directly we all know
how loving ends but i want to fall in
love with the world anyway
to let it crack me open i want to feel
what there is to feel while i am here
sendak ended that interview with the
last words he ever said
in public live your life
live your life live your life
and this is my attempt to do so
you